[Music]
welcome back to all the record where we
talk about whatever we do whatever we
want
whatever completely off the record in
public
so let that be let that be known and
that's the key to the show that's how it
works dude
david is back yes everybody i
i have returned how does it feel to sit
where you once sat before years ago
before you abandoned
the family yes son of a [ __ ] i'll tell
you this guys i don't even know where
i'm at i've been drinking so much
i literally don't know where i'm at
right now we didn't used to drink public
we're a genius brain
all right where'd you get his brain well
genius brain i drink a lot
we drink quite a lot this used to be uh
this used to be your seat yes it did
well it was that and then we brought we
brought him here
yeah yeah well then that used to be my
seat yeah this was your seat dude now i
am the guest it's fantastic okay can you
talk about the difference between
being the guest and sitting there i will
say this the best part about
jk news now don't you smile at me i'm
sorry
i'm looking this way dude this is the
fact there's some roast coming out yeah
is the fact who's gonna get roasted my
fat ass is gonna get in trouble
the women aren't here
i have a question what is your guys's
minimal amount of money that you'll take
to do a youtube boxing match
two 500 bucks versus a tick tock fighter
it's really like
no because
dude if i was serious 500 000. two bucks
i'll do it half a million
okay who who would be your opponent we
have to give somebody formidable i feel
like that's
really half a million half a million i
do it [ __ ] somebody comes to you
right now quarter million cash
you wouldn't do it no because i got to
take it seriously and i have to like be
able to go okay these are all the things
i have to say
put a pause on for six months so i need
to be compensated
the right way i'll go into debt to be in
a youtube fight 275
000 and 25 thousand dollars in ether joe
doesn't know how to invest
the clear reality is i live in a garage
and he lives in a mansion
and we're business partners so that
should tell you how he managed his money
and how i did
i can't even own a damn t-shirt come on
man
and this guy makes t-shirts we're gonna
have overalls keep your pants up
[Laughter]
what about this what about this 250 000
right okay who's that one filipino kid
that did the show with alex wasabi
the philip wrote oh roy so so roy wasabi
comes out he goes dude bart's a little
[ __ ] i'll piece him up i'll give him
250 grand
he might have really said that already
though and he said that [ __ ] and he goes
i'll [ __ ] you up any day out of the
[ __ ] week dude
what do you do and after that geo's
gonna become my wife that's what he said
he's a sweet kid dude
in this scenario i know him dude this
guy's so sweet now it's weird
yeah and he and the more he talks [ __ ]
about you his eyebrows get thicker oh
it's crazy
oh my god he said geo's gonna be my wife
after and you're just like he's a sweet
kid
he'd be good to her guys you don't get
it he never watches content
i'll make him eat the slime that he's
always [ __ ] with
250 and i use him because he's a really
nice guy 250 thousand dollars
but he's talking mad about it so stuff
like that like on the reel
stuff like that because i think like me
and joe come from
a different era we would just probably
assassinate him
i would play a game online and keep the
sweet kid [ __ ] up and i'd probably just
kill him in real life
and then we'll have a vigil be like oh
i'm so sad
what happened because i don't come from
the era of handling things like with
cameras on you know
oh yeah can i just tell you something
we just admitted to a future crime i
know
everyone thinks i have the biggest dick
in this room but i have a [ __ ] [ __ ]
right now
that [ __ ] right there dude what's your
number david what's your number
mine is half a mil okay easy i'll fight
anybody i'm gonna
you know what you guys will you fight
your mother mother
bro anybody is anybody you got a bone to
pick with her bro
he's got history are you gonna kick your
mom's ass are you gonna talk [ __ ] too
steve can i just say yeah yeah i was
just in vegas this past week that
literally kicked you out of the [ __ ]
why did you kick her in the [ __ ] she
was asking you they were just [ __ ]
[ __ ] around and then
pounced what happened i literally kicked
you
in the [ __ ] i was like yes and i have
never laughed so hard and felt satisfied
did she do anything well she wanted to
shadow box me and then she came close
and i forgot how much more leg she is
than torso and i straight
kicked her in the [ __ ] don't shadow box
david he's going for the balls why did
you do a front kick
it wasn't it was a roundhouse but then i
literally went
wait where was her [ __ ] on the side
where was jio's [ __ ] yeah does it exist
on the hip like what the [ __ ]
[ __ ] like over here i know
it was the fun i i was laughing about it
for two days straight i couldn't stop
how did she react to it it was
it was a dave chappelle stand-up thing
that came to life i kicked her in the
[ __ ]
wow it was [ __ ] but how did how did
she react did she she said it hurt
that hurt a lot and i laughed in her
face i was like i
[ __ ] kicked you with a puzzy [ __ ]
you don't say [ __ ] to me anymore
it's about your fighting your mom
let's just be real dude let's do it i'll
give you i give you five thousand
dollars to sock my mom in the face let's
make it happen
wait 5 000 that's it i can pay right now
if you want i want five thousand dollars
i'll give you five thousand dollars a
win right now
i'll just give you some stinking rewards
for like three weeks and i'll suck your
mom in the [ __ ] face
this is for that negative reinforcement
wow and i'm like why do i why did i pay
to do this
i could have done this for free i guess
i'm proving a point
men are weird
i'll be honest though if i told my mom
that for a half a million dollars i
had to piece her up she'd be like let's
do it
[Laughter]
please together let's do it right now
the pre-fight [ __ ]
with you and your mom the [ __ ]
standoff
is that the best [ __ ] is close together
why is it the best shooter
and then she goes you have something on
your face
the [ __ ] conference this piece of
[ __ ] you know what i had to do
i'm gonna do a [ __ ] instagram selfie
with my mom in the hospital with both
her lips on my stir like this
i want to see your mom come in one pound
overweight and then she has to strip
down naked
just so she'll make weight on the scale
yeah
she's like a [ __ ] are you beat made away
[ __ ] yeah i i find my mom
yeah i got to ask you this because
you're the only fighter here how would
he
fight his mom what's the advantages his
mom has you coached the mom though you
coached him i coached the mom yeah yeah
because you already know david's game
you already know his game
how did how does your his mom exploit
his game i've never uh met
david's mom before don't [ __ ] talk
about my mom that way bro what are you
doing over there bro
what are you doing right now man that's
weird you know what i i'll coach your
mom i'll call your mom and she'll [ __ ]
you up because
you know what she can do she might not
be physically fit but she can
psychologically win yes
and that's how you beat the asian uh
upbringing championships like does the
mom get a feather duster or she's like
exactly no she's gonna fight dirty bro
i'm gonna teach her how to step on feet
i'm gonna teach her how to like headbutt
i'm a teacher
i'm putting brass knuckles under that
[ __ ] punching bag man
you know david's style how does someone
beat david especially his mom
she's gonna pull out his report card hey
it's gonna be a tough fight for david's
mom
i'll just say this okay but oh i could
beat up my 80 year old one
yeah it's going to be a tough one really
well right now
i feel like anthony wouldn't be scripted
all my money's
[Laughter]
i thought we were cool
powerful imagery i'm going to hell bro
it doesn't matter i'm taking you with me
oh [ __ ]
dude life is good man i'm gonna be broke
advantages disadvantages okay um you
know what
i think david's mom has the mental
advantages i think she has
the mental well i raised this
[ __ ]
she knows things that i don't even know
about you're going to be talking [ __ ]
like
that's why you're always a c grade beach
do you know what age you are when you
got circumcised
you're not going to be late he starts
crying she's like you're not going to be
late to this punch
oh [ __ ] talking that's gonna be part of
the game and then she'll [ __ ] with them
with the sympathies like who
who had your back i'll tell you a
hundred [ __ ] percent though the last
time i was in sacramento
if i start play fighting my mom she's
always down but this [ __ ] [ __ ]
oblique kicked me
and then she pushed into my knees [ __ ]
my dad got hella mad at her he's like
why would you do that yeah hey that's
the key to victory
[ __ ] david's knees he has a knee
problem
i'll punch that [ __ ] she
literally did the leaping oblique kick
and she [ __ ] hyperextended my name
you know with all the training that i
can give to david's mom
i still think david is going to drop
david's mom with the body shot in the
fifth round i think this is how i was
doing five rounds
all the way all the way there what
happened to david in the first four
rounds
you know what i think he was trying to
figure out her timing because she's
gonna be really
unorthodox you know i mean and she's
gonna be fighting real dirty she's gonna
be clinching him the whole time but you
know i think dave is gonna win
hey guys today's video is brought to you
by fails
i love feels man because my favorite
time in the workout
always in the morning mm-hmm but
sometimes you gotta shoot workout videos
at night you know
to get me hyped up i always get
pre-workout and then
i get a really good workout in but then
now it's time to sleep and it's like
nine or ten and i'm still like
wired i'm like oh [ __ ] how do i go to
sleep good thing i got feels in my
drawer
take it out take two drops watch my
favorite movie
and then in about 30 minutes i'm like oh
way more chill
actually like naturally like dozing off
because that's like my favorite thing to
do is to like
not force myself to sleep but you know
you can feel yourself getting tired
so i like that a lot and that's what's
dope about feels it's a premium cbd
delivery service delivered right to your
door
and they got a customer service hotline
in case you want to take it like yo i'm
on bro yeah what do i do i need to chill
the [ __ ] out
yeah what's what's a movie to watch yeah
how can i calm myself down so i can
finally go to sleep
they'll probably recommend not to watch
any action movies
yeah you want to watch something chill
like minari or something like that yeah
no more documentaries i'm working out
either yeah i've chilled out the
opposite
so that's why i love feels and you can
get 50 off your first order right now if
you go to feels.com
off the record and that's f e a l s dot
com slash off the record
and you get free shipping fields.com off
the record
for 50 off plus free shipping uh so i'm
actually
starting a serious boxing training next
week yeah so it's going to be
for a purpose about it he's gonna end up
fighting bro why
well we've always trained very casually
except for in the beginning the
beginning was very serious and then
after that i was like
uh it's just kind of hard you know well
he
he just didn't want to get there yet at
that point in time when he was training
he was like i just want to learn good
though i just want to train
he was like i don't have to beat on my
mom right now so i'm just going to
casually do it
now his mom is on the target he's
getting ready i don't know what the [ __ ]
took over david where he wants to
[ __ ] fight people
why are you so angry now david well i
don't i don't want to fight people he do
want to fight people bro
this guy lying out of his eyes hold on a
second look at him
real bad all right her ass this is what
it is
pandemic has been a a really good time
for me right
because everything stopped yeah so now i
have time to do
anything that i want now i plan to
probably have a kid in about two years
so it within this two years i'm going to
get out everything that i want to do
i want to have hands so [ __ ] good
that when i go into a ring
whether you're amateur or pro you're
going to have to at least respect me
i don't want to be as good as them i
don't want to be good as a pro boxer but
they're not going to go into the ring
and be like this is going to be an easy
day
i thought that you wanted to be so good
that your kid will never beat you up
oh i'll [ __ ] up my kid no matter what
because i'm good the moment he comes out
of the [ __ ] womb i'm choking him out
with him bro
yeah don't put your father in the face
once why are you choking learn learn
learn my kid's going to beat me up when
he's
or she's six it's over yeah he or she's
i don't know man but one through five
you're gonna [ __ ] destroy them
yeah yeah nah dude i'm gonna invest
in being on their good side and be like
remember
i never abused you don't say invest to
anthony bro that's a
just wait till [ __ ] 2048 [ __ ] all
right
maybe i'll have a chance you guys are
gonna be fine i'm not gonna be alive
some of you guys gonna be rich but some
of us are gonna be square
someone's gonna break right the [ __ ]
even dude he's just right
i mean how'd you do that math how'd you
know that i'll tell you this though
there's very
there's a lot of empowerment and mental
clarity when you know that when you
could walk into a ring cage or whatever
and you could uh hold your own clothes
around it feels really [ __ ] i could
pull my own in there
but i could meet him at the parking lot
and stab him
yep one card joe's a white card
that scares me owning a shotgun i feel
that kind of power
wow i could really i could kill anything
i'll get my ass
[ __ ] up with when there's rules yeah
but i'll cowardly win
even something small like we were we
were sparring uh in uh joe's garage
just do stuff right and i was sparring
gilbert and we sparred before right
and gilbert's very weird like he's as
weird as his personality his fighting
style is just weird he has a big butt
like trump
yeah yes he does and he do got a trump
butt you got an ostrich body
all you gotta say he's got a trump
button everyone's like god [ __ ] damn
oh gilbert's built like a lego like a
lego dude like he's just sitting like
this like this he's head and ass bro
yeah but it's kind of cool like you get
to spar and then you get to land these
body shots you've never landed before in
your life and then you could see these
things
the level up of martial arts is so cool
because you never get to see
how well you get until you start
sparring and then you see it it's like
well
three months ago i couldn't land a body
shot but why am i landing it now because
i'm fighting a podcast
sidekick
name flat face maybe gilbert's face is
the easiest thing
to hit it's a flat face target right so
like
when somebody screams pan-face goo
gilbert just goes what
[Laughter]
who's talking about me i love gilbert
though he's a [ __ ] dude yeah he's great
you know you should kick howard stern's
uh sidekick chicks ass
gilbert was actually like a very well he
was like he's hella good at tech one
though so he's been martial last couple
years yeah well i i'm probably about
taekwondo so i kind of get it i kind of
get those moves
he's got a purple belt for both
taekwondo junior karate let's go
you re-take wando certified certified
we got to get steve come train with us
dude he's so tall
he would knock everybody out bro what do
you want i know forms dude [ __ ]
[ __ ] you yeah yeah yeah let's that's all
you need to know bro ah
why'd you get a taste of blood
[Laughter]
steve is going to get a taste of blood
once and it's going to transform he's
going to like it bro
it's not fair when long-lived big dudes
start learning martial arts
hated we got lots of inspiration i got
the puncher i got spider-man i got a
superman i got batman
i got [ __ ] everybody there was all
white we got it all
online don't even worry about it much
inspiration even zorro was white they
just painted on a [ __ ] mustache well
you just wait a couple decades because
we got
shang chi and and yeah oh i'm so scared
[Laughter]
yo you know what shank cheese power is
uh he's gonna do karate
and he's really good at it hey guess
what
asians have a superhero what's he do
karate
you know what was so [ __ ] funny bro
listen
yo break those stereotypes guys shout
out to [ __ ] siboulu right
but his action figure was the most
funniest [ __ ] thing i've ever seen in
my life
he literally just looks like he wears
that pen express
he has a [ __ ] broom without the head
it's like yo why are you gonna do our
guy female like that dude
i mean did they have a at least a side
of broccoli beef as a
as a [ __ ] when i saw that actually i
was so pissed
he's
[Laughter]
why can't you have like laser lip
nipples or [ __ ]
suck it let it stick the walls or
something
huh suction cup powers at least
huge penis laser eyes
everybody seems to have laser eyes
except for i guess asian superhero
they can only do karate now oh that [ __ ]
was so [ __ ] fun oh my
a white guy with a [ __ ] fu man shoe
named
raw's all ghoul we got so [ __ ]
dude what are you guys even doing
ant-man does karate iron man
everyone is [ __ ] crying why couldn't
he like read minds or something it's so
cute you guys thought you're coming up
on my [ __ ] and i'm just like yeah
[ __ ] i never thought of it that way i
kind of don't want to see the movie
anymore yo
maybe i'll be ant-man this weekend
the [ __ ] trailer was so disappointing
bro like in the beginning
really you didn't like it dude he walks
up to a wall and he just goes hi yeah
that was the beginning of the [ __ ]
trailer i was like dude you could have
done way better
by the way i've felt that way in the
subway though where he's just like
i'm like yeah no there's homeless people
around
[Laughter]
hell yeah man all of us that's relatable
all of us do
when there's homeless people around you
start doing kung fu dude i'm doing this
[ __ ]
i don't even know what this does for you
they already know kung fu in downtown
lane
every homeless person knows kung fu too
the dude in the l.a river who's got the
[ __ ]
the two sticks oh don't [ __ ] with that
guy i've talked about that fool for so
long and people thought i was lying
about this dude right
and i finally recorded him i put it on
my story like dave is not like why the
[ __ ] would i lie about this [ __ ]
but he literally had one where it was
like two like hot links it was like
sausages what
this what makes anything out of
nunchucks it's disgusting it was like
two hot links
he [ __ ] goes off for a while long
last time
like a long time knows the motion of the
hot links do you know you know that uh
that spot it's like it's the uh the
freeway passage tunnel thing where
everybody takes photos at yeah that's
where he's at
yeah oh he's there oh [ __ ] yeah he's
always practicing he's gotta be right in
these streets all the time dude
local carney he got really upset at the
asian attacks he was like these are my
people
he's black [ __ ] she ain't got no
other powers
i think he just goes kung fu and he's
just really fast i don't know
black panther does kung fu too bro yeah
but he's got a cool ass suit
yeah that's kind of like walking for
superheroes knowing kung fu
stronger than most of the superheroes
he's actually a better fighter than most
of them even
even guys even robin knows kong food
rough out there so sorry i petitioned
for
[ __ ] g2 i hope i'm hoping there's a
two
that he develops like something like
like goku you know like like he develops
as he gets better you throw like
fireballs or some [ __ ] fireballs fly
you know what was the most hilarious
thing was when uh
simulator was announced as a superhero
and then china was like but he's so
ugly dude that was so [ __ ] up
china was mad that simu was the
representation for asian americans
because in their standards of beauty
he's [ __ ] hideous is he not a good
looking dude i thought he plays good
yeah in american standards but they want
someone that's like pale than like k-pop
looking
yeah they want to see the veins in their
halves of [ __ ] oh
yeah they want to they want a k-pop boy
that [ __ ] was so [ __ ] funny it's like
everybody's proud of his accomplishments
and jenna goes like [ __ ] this guy
[ __ ] ugly guy i'm like bro that must
[ __ ] suck to have like i don't know
like one-sixth of the planet's
population consider you
i know
[Music]
them in india right yeah yeah they
basically are the world what did india
think
i don't know whatever i think
cemu is a good looking dude i feel like
he's got a good wholesome face you know
i was so surprised that india had such a
huge covert problem because one of the
funniest things that came out that's
terrible when i said that
okay one of the funniest videos that
came out when code was just popping was
there was
indian police officers beating the [ __ ]
out of civilians for not wearing a mask
like they would walk out they would walk
up to them with a cane and start canning
them in public for not wearing a mask
oh jesus so i was shocked that they had
a copy problem yeah because i thought
they were hella strict too
but there's way too many of them though
i think the strictness maybe was uh not
necessarily complementary to like the
resources they had but that's a totally
different conference back to cimu
and being like attractive or not no no
they also
um after that broke out this uh asian
media
kind of channel went out and started
interviewing people
and asking them what they thought
attractiveness-wise was
but they just have a different standard
of beauty than we do
because i was just like that is
mind-blowing that they would say that
about him
yeah i can understand if you think he's
okay-looking or whatever but ugly is
really harsh
like he's not dog dude he is not ugly
wow the [ __ ] out of you it's like the
people's republic of china like the
entire like government doctrine comes
out and you know i
bet you we must make this formal
statement on behalf of all chinese
people around the world he's like he's
not communist involved
yeah they're gonna get john cena to do
it bro john cena
just because you don't have any
supervision he's ugly i know
dude give me freeze breath or something
okay what you need to remember is that
karate
has been a superpower you're just
desensitized to it
all right every henchman that i watch in
every batman movie i guess knows that
super power
yeah that's the funniest thing they all
just do spitting heel kicks
[Music]
you